[Musica]
quanta energia
stiamo consumando in questo momento
quanta energia consumiamo durante una
video call o durante una conference call
oppure guardando un film ad alta
definizione
sicuramente la pandemia che ha colpito
il mondo ci ha costretti a ridisegnare
gli spazi le distanze le abitudini di
vita le abitudini di lavoro e ha
cambiato i consumi energetici e la
domanda energetica nel mondo
se da un lato abbassato la richiesta
energetica pensiamo per esempio al
settore dei trasporti
dall'altro ne ha alimentato altre per
esempio un consumo di dati che è esploso
e che porta oggi al 5 10 per cento del
totale
energetico con una previsione di
raddoppio entro i prossimi cinque anni
spinta da questa curiosità ho voluto
dunque calcolare l'equivalente
energetico di guardare un film per
un'ora in alta definizione o una video
call di un'ora bene l'equivalente
energetico è quello di guidare
un'automobile di bassa cilindrata una
panda diciamo per 20 chilometri
producendo ben due chilogrammi di
anidride carbonica
impressionante vero pensiamo alle mail
quante mail mandate al giorno dieci
venti forse trenta immaginiamo dunque
100 persone che mandano 30 e mail al
giorno per un anno qualcosa di direi
verosimile bene l'equivalente energetico
pensate è quello di prendere un volo
milano new york andata e ritorno per 13
volte con un consumo di tonnellate di
anidride carbonica
quando faccio una ricerca su google o
una videochiamata il consumo energetico
è un concetto forse poco concreto
astratto c'è un computer che da qualche
parte nel mondo si accende e fa tutte le
operazioni necessarie che servono a me
per il mio scopo per fare la mia ricerca
su google non ce ne rendiamo conto ma
non è irrilevante il consumo energetico
è qualcosa di veramente di alto impatto
sul nostro stile di vita quotidiano
perché qualsiasi nostra azione richiede
energia energia che può essere luce
calore energia chimica energia elettrica
ma sempre energia è il limite di quello
che possiamo fare è l'energia che
abbiamo a disposizione
ma la fame energetica è sempre maggiore
vogliamo connessioni sempre più veloci
vogliamo film in definizione sempre
maggiore in qualità maggiore macchine
sempre più potenti sempre più
performanti
e questo è il problema energetico
globale il consumo mondiale di energia è
cresciuto dal 1950 ad oggi in modo
esponenziale con un aumento del 500 50
per cento
questo è dovuto all'aumento della
popolazione globale della data
all'adattamento alle sfide tecnologiche
al miglioramento degli stili di vita e
sarà sempre maggiore
per affrontare questo problema ci
dobbiamo dunque chiedere quanta energia
abbiamo a disposizione
allora facciamo una analogia con un
conto in banca che alimentiamo ogni fine
mese se prendessimo da questo conto se
prelevati modà questo conto al 15 del
mese
ovviamente non avremo le risorse
sufficiente per arrivare a fine mese e
questo quello che sta succedendo un
pochino con le risorse energetiche oggi
si parla infatti di overshoot day ovvero
il giorno in cui la domanda mondiale di
energia
equipara la possibilità di
riequilibrare questa energia è in
qualche modo quando abbiamo raggiunto
l'over sciuto e dei noi abbiamo finito
le risorse energetiche
dunque negli anni settanta cadeva fine
anno ma oggi cade ad agosto
hanno un po in analogia con il 15 del
mese del nostro conto in banca
finiamo le risorse prima che la terra
sia capace di rigenerarle questo si sta
avvicinando sempre di più e questo è un
problema reale
da dove deriva l'energia quindi che
consumo è bene sapere che ancora oggi la
maggior parte dell'energia deriva dalla
combustione di sorgenti fossili petrolio
carbone che hanno un ruolo dominante sul
cambiamento climatico
con una percentuale del 60 per cento di
contributo sulle emissioni di co2
quindi qualunque cosa che facciamo
richiede un consumo di energia consumo
di energia portai immissioni di co2 e
maggiori sono le emissioni di co2 più il
pianeta si riscalda e più la vita
diventerà insostenibile
potete dunque immaginare la complessità
della sfida energetica globale di oggi
consumiamo energia la dobbiamo anche
produrre per garantire sostenibilità
ambientale energetica sostenibilità di
vita
entro il 2050 si stima che le
rinnovabili avranno un ruolo
fondamentale
e potranno portare al 73 a cooper
potranno contribuire al 70 per cento del
fabbisogno energetico globale il solare
avrà un ruolo dominante nel panorama
energetico
ricoprendo entro il 2050 il 30 per cento
del fabbisogno energetico con una
riduzione del 50 per cento di anidride
carbonica
l'italia è uno dei paesi più virtuosi in
questo rispetto agli altri paesi europei
con un record in lombardia di impianti
fotovoltaici
installati di oltre 130.000 dunque
il fotovoltaico è davvero una risorsa
energetica molto attraente
pensate che l'energia proveniente dalla
luce solare
sulla terra e quasi tremila volte
l'energia di cui il mondo intero ha
bisogno un energia abbondante e gratuita
pensando oggi al solare che cosa vi
viene in mente a me viene in mente
qualcosa di questo tipo una casa con i
pannelli fotovoltaici installati sul
tetto
sono moduli fotovoltaici al silicio una
tecnologia presente da molti anni sul
mercato e ad oggi la soluzione
commerciale più diffusa
una tecnologia come vi dicevo presente
già da una settantina di anni sviluppata
negli anni 50 che come vedete da queste
immagini non è molto variata negli
ultimi anni è la stessa tecnologia
l'aspetto del dei moduli fotovoltaici è
sempre lo stesso
oggi però le necessità sono un po
cambiate le necessità sono diverse e
richiedono un fotovoltaico moderno il
fotovoltaico al silicio una tecnologia
interessante una tecnologia matura ed
efficiente ha dei limiti estetici che
non lo rendono facilmente integrabili
nell'ambiente circostante come per
esempio nell'ambiente montano ma non
solo anche nelle nostre città è una
tecnologia a poco adatta forse alle
nostre ai nostri billing ai nostri
edifici alle nostre città
forse non più pronta a rispondere alle
esigenze moderne
oggi vi mostro invece qualcosa di
completamente innovativo è la tecnologia
fotovoltaica del futuro quella che
sviluppiamo dei laboratori
dell'università di pavia una tecnologia
nuova bella colorata ed innovativa ed
ora vi spiego perché
il fotovoltaico definito ha pero skeet e
è un fotovoltaico innovativo che in soli
dieci anni di ricerca ha raggiunto
efficienze paragonabili a quelle del
silicio sono materiali ibridi
che formano questa bellissima struttura
cristallina
composta da materiali organici plastici
e inorganici insieme
è un materiale innovativo perché viene
prodotto con delle tecnologie
estremamente semplici si parte dalle
polveri si dissolvono in soluzione
formando degli inchiostri delle vernici
spalmabili su qualunque tipo di
superficie
chi può essere il vetro chi può essere
la plastica che può essere un tessuto
senza limiti di applicazioni come vedete
in pochissimi step si forma questo film
sottile sottile come 100 volte più
sottile di un capello
di colore scuro capace di assorbire in
modo molto efficiente tutta la luce
visibile dello spettro solare una
tecnologia dunque molto promettente e
molto innovativa
innovativa ripeto perché si sviluppa a
partire da inchiostri liquidi che
possono essere stampati come su fogli di
giornale o come vernici su qualunque
tipo di superficie
con un processo a costo minimo ea minimo
contenuto energetico
ricordo ancora quando nel 2010
lavoravo come
studente di dottorato di ricerca con
all'università di oxford e con il mio
collega mike li stavamo maneggiando i
primi prototipi di film di per uscite
ibrida e lui mi disse giulia ter
something magic in età giulia c'è
qualcosa di particolare di magico dietro
a questi materiali
guardando veramente stupefatti queste
celle solari con un'efficienza molto
alta un inchiostro capace di assorbire
la luce e generare corrente
dal 2010 in poi la tecnologia ha subito
una crescita record ed è stata definita
nel 2016 come una delle top ten
technologies dal world economic forum
dunque innovativo perché ha le
potenzialità di rispondere alle esigenze
moderne di un fotovoltaico moderno è
possibile creare moduli colorati come
quelli che vi ho mostrato
trasparenti
allo stesso tempo funzionali e belli
il potenziale immenso pensate agli
edifici alle nuove costruzioni
questi moduli possono essere integrati
facilmente come essi stessi elementi
architettonici
permettendo dunque di dare una funzione
nuova agli elementi pensate alle
finestre che non sono solo finestre ma
che diventano al contempo sorgenti di
energia
dunque una sfida complessa quella
energetica che richiede una ricerca
scientifico tecnologica
altrettanto complessa che deve mettere
insieme esperienze e una conoscenza
multidisciplinare dalla chimica dei
materiali alla fisica dei processi
all'ingegnerizzazione di dispositivi
funzionanti
efficienti e sostenibili
come le pero schiti quelle che di cui vi
ho parlato oggi che io credo siano
capaci di illuminare il paradigma del
solare del futuro che inizia a partire
da oggi grazie